[Music]
we can all use some help during our
parenting journey and today we chat with
a prior educator on some tips for
success if you're looking for a strong
support group and a better connection
with your own children
jennifer cervantes was a prior educator
and is currently the founder of tough as
a mother tribe her first tip
be vulnerable with other parents share
how you really feel and what you're
struggling with
being real will help build a strong
support system and help others guide you
with things you may struggle with
her second tip be present with your kids
do something fun together and it doesn't
even have to cost a penny
i remember like not growing up with a
lot of money like but i remember
all the things we did a lot of them were
free and that's going back to public
school teaching
i taught thousands of kids and after
every monday when they would talk about
what they did over the weekend it was
never like
oh look at my new shirt or this
sometimes it was among peers but
you know listening in on for over a
decade kids
always talked about what and we're so
fulfilled with the things that
going fishing going on a picnic that
really meant something to them
the last tip be honest with your kids
talk through key issues that are
happening in your life and around the
world kids are intuitive we often want
to protect them by not sharing
but by knowing what's going on around
them it helps children build a solid
connection with you
and by sharing your feelings your
children will feel safer when they're in
the loop
and when you communicate openly and
honestly with them